In this lesson, we've seen that there
are some problems that we can not
compute in a traditional
programming language like Python.
But somehow this feels
a bit unsatisfying,
since all we showed was there
are more problems to solve than there
are computer programs to solve them.
But we haven't actually given
you any specific problem
that can't be solved on a computer.
The set of problems with finite
descriptions accountable, so
at this point we haven't even ruled out
that every problem we can describe
we can solve in a computer.
Turns out this isn't the case,
there's some very natural problems that
cannot be solved by computers,
now or ever.
To get to that point we need more tools.
We need to find some model of
computation simple enough to study yet
powerful enough to capture
everything we mean by computing.
In the next lecture we
do exactly that and
introduce you to
the wonderful Turing machine.